this presentation is delivered by the
Stanford center for professional
development now let's get started I'd
like to welcome you again to today's
webinar entitled project innovation
through design thinking today's session
is being sponsored by the Stanford
center for professional development and
the Stanford advanced project management
certificate program it is my pleasure
today to introduce Professor Pamela J
Heinz and Michael berry to esteemed
colleagues and subject matter experts on
design thinking and innovation
professor Heinz is an associate
professor and management science and
engineering and the co-director of the
Center for work technology and
organizations at Stanford her research
and teaching levers of social sciences
organizational behavior in particular to
understanding the effects of technology
on groups and teams and organizations
professor Heinz is currently researching
how design practices and Design Thinking
vary in different regions around the
world
she believes that culture context shapes
the practices that are possible and
appropriate in different settings and
that honoring these differences is the
key to innovation Michael berry is a
consulting assistant professor in the
design School in the mechanical
engineering department at Stanford
University where he teaches need finding
and cross-cultural design Michael is
also a guest lecturer at the Harvard
School of Business and University of
California Haas School of Business a
founder of point forward Michael has
over two decades of experience providing
strategic innovation at the critical
early stages of the product development
process
he has restructured research and
innovation processes provided strategic
project management and designed over 80
products from mainframes to disposable
diapers his clients include Sony IBM
Nestle Wells Fargo Wrigley and many
other companies his teams have received
numerous awards from ID magazine IDSA
and Businessweek I'd like to welcome Pam
Hines and Michael berry
Thank You forever so today we're going
to talk about project innovation through
design thinking and then we'll have a
little bit about how we learn more about
these courses and followed up with about
10 minutes of Q&A so our objective for
today is to give you some familiarity
with the design thinking process and
some insight into how it can be used to
reframe project opportunities for people
who are working on projects project
managers and so forth so let me start
with a couple of quick examples of how
people have used a design thinking
process to make changes in their
organizations first embrace which is a
small startup company in Palo Alto
created a portable incubator focused on
saving the lives of babies in developing
countries and I'll go into a little bit
more detail on that case in a few
minutes
JetBlue a domestic US airline use design
thinking as well as lean processes to
really rethink their business operations
as a result they went from a cost of 41
million dollars to recover from an ice
storm in 2007 to a cost of about 10
million for the one that happened in
2010 in large part due to some of the
operational changes that they made in a
project that we did on global aging we
interviewed seniors around the globe and
learned that remaining independent isn't
actually a value in all cultures we
discovered in China that in fact seniors
weren't lonely they had actually really
active social lives but they missed
their children and grandchildren who had
left to pursue other opportunities in
distant region
or countries and that suggested a very
different kind of product or service
opportunity to support these seniors in
China and then finally working with the
American Heart Association they came to
us saying that they actually had a
problem with CPR training in China
people simply weren't signing up and
learning to do CPR when going in to
really understand this problem in China
our team discovered that in fact
training wasn't really the issue but it
was that if somebody had a cardiac
incident in China the likelihood of them
surviving was actually quite low and the
last person who touched them would
actually be held accountable for their
death so there was a real risk to people
if they actually used CPR in China which
suggested a real reframing of the
problem - one that was much more about
policy and helping people to see the
value of being heroes and actually doing
CPR in that context so what is design
thinking well it's a philosophy and it's
a mindset it's really a mindset around
how you approach problems and
opportunities and one of the beliefs
that we have in design thinking is that
just about everything we encounter every
day is designed anything that's not
nature of course - the trees and grass
and so forth are not designed by people
but just about everything else this this
webinar the computer that you're working
on the seat that the chair that you're
sitting in just about everything you
encounter has been designed by somebody
and that's true for processes that we
encounter services that we encounter and
so forth and just about everything could
be designed better there's a real
opportunity to improve
the experiences that people have so the
focus of design thinking is really on
redesigning experiences experiences of
products experiences of services for
example when you go to restaurants or
hotels and experiences of processes for
example HR processes reviews performance
management in organizations operational
processes and so forth in all of those
cases they are experienced by people and
it's important to understand that
experience in order to improve those
products services or processes so I'm
going to go into a little bit more
detail on a few of these case studies to
give you a sense of how they're being
used but also a sense of the process
starting with embrace so 140 million
babies die each year 4 million of those
die in the first 28 days of life and
most of those are in developing
countries around the world so this team
at Stanford was challenged with an
opportunity to design a less expensive
incubator so the cost of incubators is
around $20,000 and they were asked to
design an incubator that cost no more
than $300 with the idea being that if
there were more incubators available at
a lower cost they'd be able to help
these fragile children to survive those
past the first 28 days of life so what
this team did was they went into the
context they went to India and they
looked at the hospitals and we looked at
the incubators and they thought about
how people were actually using
these incubators in the hospital
environment so what do you notice to
take a second to write down what you
notice about these pictures that are on
your screen okay so there are two things
that I want to point out one is there's
actually a lot of incubators one of the
things that they found when they went
into these hospitals is even though
incubators cost $20,000 or more they
were actually readily available in the
hospitals that they went into in these
urban areas the other thing that you
might notice is that these incubators
are empty so what they found was that in
fact the incubators were there that the
babies weren't making their way into the
hospitals in order to be put into the
incubators so the team then went to the
village and tried to understand why the
babies weren't making it to the
incubators and the problem was that the
babies again these are fragile children
early days of life often born premature
often very low birth weight and they
were simply too fragile to make the
journey into the urban areas to be
placed in these incubators so the team
did then was reframe the problem they
said the problem is not building a
cheaper incubator the problem is finding
a way to transport these very fragile
babies from these rural villages into
the towns where the hospitals were and
where the incubators were located so
they went back they brainstormed they
did a lot of prototyping built over 100
prototypes and they ended up with a
sleeping bag type of our architecture
that had a very special insert with
phase change materials that would keep
the babies warm as they were being
transported and it didn't rely on
electricity which was really critical
but they didn't stop there they then
went back into these villages and got
feedback from people they found out how
the mothers would actually hold these
how they would put the babies in what
were the fears and taboos around using
these how would they carry them from the
villages into the city and so forth and
they then or that feedback back into the
design of the product which ended up
looking something like this
so the solution looks pretty simple but
incubators have been around for over a
hundred years and have been a standard
for treating premature babies so it's
not just a new product but a paradigm
that has the potential to rewrite how
the babies are treated especially where
the products or the problem is really
occurring
okay so that was an example of a product
and some of you out there might be
saying well you know we're project
managers we don't design products we
design processes and work with project
teams well I want to share with you now
a little bit more detail on the JetBlue
case because this is about operational
excellence
so what JetBlue found was at different
parts of the organization we're acting
independently for example the system
controller in the command center has to
make a decision about cancelling a
flight but he or she has no idea how
that decision might affect the
reservation agent for example who's
located in Salt Lake City or the flight
attendants who have to be rescheduled
and fly on different flights so one
things they started with was building
empathy focusing on understanding the
next person in the process so somebody
in the command center for example went
to Salt Lake City to try to understand
what you know how does the reservation
agents actually do their job what do
they do and how do my decisions or how
might
decisions actually affect their ability
to do their work so they lived in the
other guys shoes in order to be able to
build this empathy the result of all
this was the realization that they
needed to be much more consistent in how
they handled events especially what was
considered a large versus a small
disruption you know as a disruption in a
large disruption 20 flights 40 flights
100 flights being canceled do they have
to be delayed just 1 hour 2 hours 6
hours does it matter whether it's JFK a
huge airport or Palm Beach a small
airport what they ended up doing was
developing this chart that identified
what was a large disruption what was a
small disruption and how each of those
would play out in terms of the
communication the processes what got
cancelled and how that would be handled
so this framework which was operation
plan B was then prototyped repeatedly
over about a year they talked with
potential users to understand the impact
but it would have on them they thought
about how they would use it and what it
would mean for their jobs and their
ability to serve customers it was
finally rolled out in February of 2009
and as of October 2011 there actually
hadn't been any changes to it they've
gotten it to the point where it was
really working effectively for them so
now I'm going to show you a video that
was of employees at JetBlue
and their response to this program
okay so that gives you an idea of how it
actually changed the experience of
employees at JetBlue so what is this
design thinking process of giving it a
couple of cases that illustrate the
process but now I want to show you an
actual diagram that captures it and two
things I want to point out about this
diagram one one of things you might
notice is that the define defining the
problem actually doesn't happen at the
beginning so for example with the
embrace you know defining the problem
might be build a cheaper incubator but
in fact the problem doesn't get defined
until after this empathy stage really
understanding observing getting a sense
of what it is that people need and in
just a minute or two Michael's going to
go into much more detail on that part of
the process the other thing I want to
point out here is that although this
looks linear you know going with
understanding on the left to test on the
right in fact there are a lot of little
lines and loops between and that's meant
to capture how iterative this process is
meant to be and how important it is to
learn and then return to earlier stages
the process in order to refine the ideas
that are being developed so with that
I'm going to turn it over to Michael
berry who's going to be talking in more
detail about some aspects of the design
thinking process great Thank You Pam
enjoyed that um back to the question of
why are we doing Design Thinking isn't
this just smart people figuring out
problems and we would say that it's not
just smart people figuring out problems
but the nature of the problem that's
being asked of them and providing them
tools that actually allow them to deal
with a different quality and kind of
problem so to give you an example of
what I mean
what's the answer to this problem five
plus five I'll let you all think of that
in your heads actually ask that from a
group of Auditors last week and it took
me five minutes to get enhancer this is
not a trick question so the answer is
ten yes one one answer and no one should
have had too much trouble with it what's
the answer to this problem
okay question plus question equals to
him and I may get some answer is the
first round or oh there's probably a
hundred answers oh there's maybe a
thousand well there's an incident number
of answers here and as we get into
imaginary numbers etc what's the very
first question you should be asking as
you look at this and it's why do I want
ten because until I know why I want him
I can't even begin to address the
infinite number of solutions possible
that's the kind of problem design
thinking is good for and the fundamental
kind of dumb questions we have to ask in
order to practice it so this category of
problem has been referred to as wicked
problems it sometimes gets mixed up with
systems theory etc but the point is
you're dealing with multivariable
problems where there's in perfect
knowledge right so let's look at another
example about why we are doing design
thinking um look I asked you guys what's
this um and for those of you who have
been purchasing house cleaning products
it is the latest vacuum cleaner from
iRobot it travels around your house
sucks up dirt finds its way back to its
recharging station quite obedient
programmable kind of cute thing and
doing pretty well now you'd ask you know
why am i showing this is an example of
this new kind of wicked problem right
it's just a vacuum cleaner that's maybe
a little smarter than other vacuum
cleaners
I think the point is there's a very big
difference between iRobot and arguably
the Dyson which is best vacuum on the
block and I'd throw out to you guys
what's the difference between these two
by the way the iRobot doesn't suck all
that well it has little multiple suction
and cleaning but compared to the Dyson
doesn't do so well and it has to do with
this notion of reframing the problem
Dyson is kind of the final perfect
sucking machine
it's what the industry is defined is a
good product vacuum that sucks better
and Dyson did an amazing job engineering
it getting rid of the bag using all
kinds of venturi and vortex technologies
um at the end of the day you still have
to use it I Robot on the other hand came
from a company that manufactured
minesweepers these minesweepers were
relatively autonomous found their way
across battlefield located mines
exploded them and they asked themselves
what else could we do with our very
sophisticated technology in another
field and they thought about Oh what
about vacuuming homes and iRobot was
born what's interesting is as you turn
it on it says how patients I don't clean
as well as other vacuums but I'll be
cleaning all the time I'll be cleaning
in places you can't get to or I'll be
cleaning when you're doing something
else what was done here with a
fundamental refrain and a refrain by the
way that the vacuum cleaner companies
themselves could never get to and if any
of you have any doubts about iRobot it's
currently being looked at certainly in
Silicon Valley is the very first
successful home robot it's the lead into
essentially a new I would argue
generation of products they're about to
come so keep eyes on it but it's a
fascinating refrain um so reframing
problems in very interesting ways and
the point is a reframe is it opens the
opportunity space it gives
you a different set of solutions than
you had before so let's look at this one
more time and this was an exercise done
in an entrepreneurship class at Stanford
by Tina Seelig and I'll ask you guys I'm
going to give you an envelope and inside
the envelope is five dollars once you
open the envelope you have two hours to
make as much money as you possibly can
now that should get some people's hearts
beating so think about what would you do
what would you do with five bucks and
two hours right there you're on campus
um so start kind of imagining what's the
things you would do we had a Chinese
group here and they all said oh we'd run
to the bookstore we'd buy t-shirts and
we'd sell them right we'd sell them back
we'd make lots of money and how much
more money oh if I'd double our money
maybe triple it right so now that you
kind of thought about the things you do
what did our students do well let me
tell you what the three top students
came up with so number three number
three went out and they bought a bicycle
pump with the $5 and over the two hours
they went out in the middle of campus
where everyone's riding bicycles and
they said $1.00 and we will fill up your
tires right we'll reinflates or tires
well they didn't do so good all right
the money wasn't coming in so after the
next half hour they reduced it from $1
to 25 cents weren't getting anybody and
then somebody said oh heck let's just
we'll do it for free and give us
donations they made 50 bucks things
completely changed 50 dollars after two
hours so they came back feeling really
good that was number three number two in
the class said you know what you know I
think the five dollars is a red herring
hmm they've given it to us but we don't
have to use that it's the time the time
is what's valuable here right so it's
time and our effort so they went out to
University Avenue on Stanford where
there are all kinds of restaurants
Friday night and
US taxes can be lines everywhere and
they did line sitting right they took
the team members they said for $10 we
will hold your place in line right you
can go shop when you come back we'll
have your cell phone right we'll alert
you to when you're ready to go that team
made two hundred and fifty dollars okay
two hundred and fifty out of five
dollars what was number one what was
number one number one team one scene in
it was a you skate Japanese student
figured this one out he said you know
what the five dollars and the two hours
all our red herrings they're getting in
the way that's not what's of most value
by the way the presentation all of the
results were being presented to the
Entrepreneurship group and to the class
and they were being presented the
students would had 15 minutes he
recognized that the most valuable thing
they had to offer was the presentation
time he sold the presentation time to
Cisco to pitch a hundred of the most
talented entrepreneurs at Stanford he
sold it for $6,000 okay
so an example of what you can do with
design thinking okay with reframing and
I put up this slide and certainly what
we're talking about is not a new problem
right and the problem is a wise leader a
wise designer wise manager must first
define the right problem to solve in the
first place right and to recognize what
the value is or what the issues are that
are critical not just points of pain or
accepting the assignment learning
different ways to approach and challenge
your problem so I'm going to take one
more pass that Pam gave you a kind of
linear these are the activities around
design thinking process I want to give
you another way of looking at the design
thinking process that gets into both
some of the tools and some of the ways
of thinking that are involved in does
I'm thinking because it's not just one
way of thinking so first I want to start
and I'm going to give you a two by two
but within any design management
activity there's usually two things we
need to deal with there's an analysis
component and a synthesis component in
the analysis part I need to take apart
the problem I see as constituent parts
ask why a lot the synthesis is putting
it back together right how do I
accomplish putting it back together in a
new way that will create new value that
will serve my customers better so that's
that's one continuum there's another
continuum we like to cross it and a
problem and my way of thinking about it
it'll be in the concrete world it's
actual I can experience it I can share
those experiences I can model that
experience in some way and get concrete
reactions the other when I'm defining a
problem is the abstract world and the
abstract world is the world of models of
ideas where I conceptualize the problem
and put it in simplified terms that I
can mediate and work on and play with
okay so that's the space Design Thinking
exists in and then let's look at the
different quadrants and the kinds of
activities that exist the first one when
I'm in the kind of analytic space and
concrete I'm observing I'm observing
hopefully with fresh eyes and that's the
hard part
but I'm observing trying to understand
what's going on what are the issues what
are the complexities and then as I move
through I hope from those observations
to gain insights I try to see that world
in a new way and in that insight I may
see contradictions right where someone
tells me one thing and does another like
the infant case I may just see something
that others hadn't seen right
there where are the babies and nobody
had asked where are the babies that was
a crucial insight or in the money
figuring out really what was a value
then as I moved through into the space
and now I'm shifting from the analytic
side to the synthetic side still in the
abstract I start coming up with ideas
lots of ideas right about what's
possible from both my observation and my
insight not just coming up with wacky
ideas I'm coming up with ideas that are
consistent with the new knowledge I have
with the new frames with how the culture
works but again satisfying those needs
creating values in new ways and lastly I
need to come up with actual solutions
back in the real world that people can
experience that I can test and once more
go into observations so we've drawn this
as a linear process and as Pam said yeah
we showed you a bunch of circles in
order but the reality is it isn't linear
it operates in a very nonlinear way but
we kind of need to teach it in this
fashion I'm going to show you this slide
and these are really the tools these are
the tools that exist within these spaces
and I'll just kind of walk through
empathy is an absolutely key key tool
and it sounds easy right you know we say
Oh walk a mile in someone else's shoes
but we think of it not just as
understanding other people but
understanding them from their point of
view not ours and oh that's a hard one
and you've got to ask really dumb why
questions and it's often hard for smart
people to have dumb questions up at the
top this thing called insight and you
know we've represented it sort of the
Newtonian Apple dropping on somebody's
head but it's that aha moment it takes
time it takes collaboration sometimes
the insight falls out sometimes you have
to work at it very hard with models and
in the course we'll be providing you
with some of the ways we often use to
garner insight as we move into the
synthesis side we've represented
a diverge converge we're in divergent
thinking I'm coming up with lots of
ideas converging how do I select those
few key ones that are going to really
help there's another way of looking at
this and it has to do with a notion we
refer to as powers of 10 an MPhil that's
brilliant
and you may have seen as as high school
students it suggests that there are many
different perspectives and you're going
to find it perspective and looking at
the problem that suddenly ideas start to
come out it's it this way of looking at
it that it's generative lastly we move
into this notion of storytelling and
storytelling is something we find not
just the end delivery of a PowerPoint
presentation but something critical in
both framing the problem in a way that
an organization can make an action on so
with that really simplified and that's a
whole lot to remember we don't expect
you the end of the day it's about
figuring out what the story is and
telling a new one so I want to give you
one more case study another way to drill
down a little deeper and it's going to
be looking at some needs use usability
meaning and a story of acorns a very old
story of acorns it's a story that exists
and came out of the California Central
Valley Fresno and Madera counties and it
involves the Native American mono
Indians and these Indians ate
exclusively black and white acorns for
their starch men hunted game women as it
turns out I took care of creating bread
food from acorns and next slide this is
and by the way this is a story that
lasted for thousands of years
and this picture was taken at the turn
of the century and you're seeing an
Indian woman probably in her 70s on age
unknown but very senior woman grinding
acorns and it was referred to as a
community mill essentially two pieces of
granite big ones she's sitting on in the
one in her hand and she pounds
acorns and separates the the inner meal
edible eel from the shell another view
of that community meal in order to feed
the tribe they had to have lots of
people working together actually all the
women of the tribe were creating a corn
meal and it was a hard back-breaking job
so I want to show you the next picture
and imagine and again it's an
interactive class but I can only
interact with the people here in the
room so with that I'm going to throw it
open what are the needs
this woman has looking at this picture
yeah let's move acorns
she needs a corn how does it always Beth
and that yes that's it so a post it
would go over the wall she needs acorns
she needs to feed her people what what
other needs does she have since been
granted to grind those acorns well she
needs granite now that's interesting
because what you said and it's not wrong
but it's kind of stated solution right
and we like to think of needs as verbs
so what's the what's the granite doing
for it's breaking the accordant break in
the acorn so she needs to break de corns
open and what other needs does she have
well then I guess I would get into her
personal means means the strength and
the energy to do that absolutely it
takes a lot of strengthen I got to tell
you looking at this picture I'm not sure
I'd be up for that
so strengthen energy and as we find
certainly the engineering students
hearing this are thinking about Gyr ways
to to multiply her strength and energy
and gee maybe I can come up with a
better mortar and pestle little
optimized and break so as I said we have
all these things going on now but let's
keep going what other needs do you see
that she has manpower more people the
helpers got more people so certainly all
the women in the tribe it turns out the
children children are there as well so
we've kind of tapped out the men but
absolutely she needs lots of person
power or certainly a multiplier
to increase their output what else what
other needs a plan and that's
interesting because we've only shown you
a single snapshot but certainly there is
a whole plan of everything from
gathering the acorns bringing them into
the community rock separating them
cooking them so we've only saw your
snapshot and maybe understanding that
larger plan would give us some sense of
what to do so just just stay with it a
little longer any other any other needs
and this is what we do with you guys we
keep asking you this question to your
eyes cross anything else
anything else you know I don't know
okay well contention that it's hot and
it's certainly the pictures suggest not
much in the waves yeah I need water
I maybe need some shade we have a lot of
folks who often go wow she looks
uncomfortable yet maybe if we could get
her a chair maybe we could support her
work tasks in some way all absolutely
right and what we're kind of starting
with and by the way you hit and these
are looking at a useful way of
organizing needs first one is use right
she needs a course you need food it's
the explicit need tasks to be solved and
we're pretty good at understanding that
and we then get into this notion of
usability and most of the answers we get
in regards to this has to do with how do
we improve either the physical
ergonomics the cotman how do we make
cognitive sense out of it how do we help
her achieve the use function okay the
use needs then as you might guess
especially from the engineering students
who said you know she needs a better
food processor arm we're going to come
up with a grinder will in fact US
government did this
and provided the mono Indians with whole
25/30 grinders that they thought would
satisfy them now I'm not sure what the
Indians were doing with a c-clamp but
nonetheless they were given these
grinders which as it turns out were
never used they rusted in the rain so
what went wrong it seems like the
perfect solution all right they could
have multiples using inside it would
multiply the force everything worked and
the US government kind of set back and
said these people are just crazy they're
just not suspecting me not to use this
and to help deal with their hunger
problems what they didn't look at was
the meaning right what do a corns mean
and by the way when approaching this
problem and it's very common we say it's
a food processing problem right she
doesn't have the right food processor
but let's look and by the way the
meaning these are the cultural stories
and I mention the term culture this is
what we focus on right
it's the organizing frame emotional
resonance the expectations that these
people have around any solution so I'm
going to take you through a quick
interview okay so I wouldn't say tell me
about making acorns and the answer might
be you know it's really a hard time
consuming task right it's like whoa
sounds like a grinder to me huh next
question um well how do you do any
quantity always done it this way oh yeah
yeah you know from the village to this
Boulder you know we've always come and
done this we work you know we sit we
pound acorns we gossip you know we
scroll the children and we make food for
the tribe now a good interview and this
is something we try and teach session
ethnographic interviewer tries to listen
for the things that are outliers and I'm
talking about food then she's starting
to talk about children and childcare and
that's kind of interesting
so I may ask you know what are the
children doing alright well you know the
children may play nearby and they can
hear our stories and songs interesting
so a really astute interviewer might ask
about those songs well you know tell me
about the songs and stories but
you know we seem to pass the time and we
you know tell stories and sing songs of
our people and how they live in the
world and then I some really sharp I say
could you sing me one of those songs and
oh by the way does the song have
anything to do with making acorns and I
get the answer well of course it does
though you know that where were you
brought up everybody knows that acorns
oh you're so dumb the acorn is mother to
us all and this stone is where we give
her life through that pounding and
activity and by doing that she gives us
life what happened is those grinders
could in no way give life to the Acorn
now this is an animistic people and in
their world that was the nature of the
process that was critical and it was
critical on this meaning in any solution
needed to deal with that now again we
could simply say oh there's nothing I
can do
all right or I can begin to acknowledge
the needs that I heard and combine them
with this new meaning and stop thinking
of it as a food processing problem and
potentially start thinking of it as a
musical instrument problem
so with that needs our gaps within use
usability and meaning and we innovate by
creating new stories that bridge those
gaps between all three use usability and
meaning so with that statement and we'd
like to think that Design Thinking does
more than simply make better things
making a better tool okay yes you can do
that but you can also make things better
right and taking that large review with
that I'd like to turn it back over to
Pam okay thank you Michael so we've
talked a lot about the design thinking
process and given a few examples but I
want to do is to sort of wrap it up and
talk a little bit about project
innovation particularly in the project
management space so as we talked about
it
caning design thinking is really about
redesigning experiences of products
services processes and anything else
really that creates an experience and
project management does that it creates
an experience for employees for others
in the organization for vendors
basically anyone that the project
management activity touches so you might
ask yourself the question how might we
create project management practices that
for example lead to excitement and
engagement among the people involved
create a more cohesive team are more
dynamic given the kind of speed and
dynamism of the world in which we're
working are effective for Millennials
this new generation that has really
different needs and perhaps very
different meanings that they associate
with these processes or ones that
resonate with people around the globe or
even around the organization that are
coming from you know really different
perspectives and these are just a couple
of different examples it really is is
meant to be provocative to help you get
thinking about what are some of the
opportunities for innovation in the
project management space what are the
meanings that people associate with
things like design reviews project plans
and so forth so if we go back to the
diagram that Michael talked about first
stage is figuring out the story what is
it that people are doing with these
processes how are they responding to
them what are the things that aren't
working well what are the things that
just sort of rub or great as people
engage in this project management
practices what are the meanings of these
things you know what does it mean to
people when they go to a design review
or when they present at a design review
how can we tap more into
the meanings that really resonate for
people and begin to tell a new story
that innovates project management in
really important radical ways that
dramatically improve people's experience
and the outcomes of the project
management process so with that I'm
going to turn it back to Robert thank
you
Thank You Pam and Michael at this time
we encourage you the audience to submit
your questions about today's
presentation our presenters will answer
your questions in a couple of minutes
while we gather questions I'd like to
briefly share some information about the
Stanford advance project management
certificate program and a little bit
more about this innovation course in
1999 Stanford professor ray Leavitt
partnered with the Stanford center for
professional development and IPS
learning to create this award-winning
program focus on strategy execution and
management of project-based work this
program can be delivered in three ways
on Stanford's campus via online
streaming video and at work brought to
your company site to earn the
designation of Stanford certified
project manager participants complete
three required courses and three
elective courses from a variety of
topics to create a customized curriculum
our presenters today are faculty in the
innovation course entitled project
innovation through design thinking the
course will be offered September 19th
through the 21st of this year
so before we move to the question and
answer portion of today's presentation I
would like to open our second poll of
the day what is your level of interest
in the essay p.m. certificate program I
am interested in attending this course
on innovation I'm interested in
attending a course in September on
campus but not quite sure which one I'm
interested in bringing the S APM program
to my company I'm interested in the
online courses or not sure send me more
information about the program and let me
decide and the last one is I'm already
currently enrolled I just wanted to see
what you guys are up to now okay
the polls will close in a few seconds
but please keep clicking your answers
and the polls are now closed right thank
you very much for for your feedback
now we'll go on to the
question-and-answer portion of today's
presentation Pam and Michael our first
question is I hear it's all about
empathy and brainstorming but how do I
make this actionable okay
great question I think a lot of
companies have gone through kind of
design innovation processes and the
sense that lots and lots of ideas come
out but you don't quite know what to do
with them and I think it's actually only
looking at a small part of a process and
I think the issue about both
understanding people deeply as a way to
give you a better set of solutions the
other and more important one is this
notion of reframing and I know we've
feels like we're talking about that a
great deal but the sense of finding out
not just what is the right problem you
should be working on is crucial but more
importantly finding different ways to
begin to access that problem right and I
talked about opportunity space creating
not just a set of answers but a
different set of opportunity spaces that
starts to give you very different
answers than you had before or begins to
suggest different kinds of strategy on
how to use those answers so for us
ideation is important but only a small
part of a larger way of thinking let me
just add to that we talked as as Michael
said a lot about the empathy and the
reframing piece and the time that we had
today but there are other pieces of the
design thinking process that are also
really crucial that we didn't have time
to really drill down into and one of
those is the the prototyping process
which is a really really important
process for beginning to make tongue
these ideas make them concrete have the
team engaged in making them concrete and
then use them to go back out for example
in the JetBlue case to take that
operations plan go back out interact
with people around it
figure out and we're going to be used
and then improve it so that it really in
fact does meet the need and will in fact
be effective at doing what it's meant to
in the organization so those are really
that that loop that Michael showed you
is a really important piece looping back
around getting that feedback and
changing our understanding of the
problem so that we really get it right
great our next question is this sounds
great
but I can't do it alone how can I
actually do it in my organization panel
let you wrestle it Alan yes that's a
great question and we get that
frequently where people say you know
it's you know it takes multiple people
to do this I can't just do design
thinking on my own and that's absolutely
true it's really about creating a
culture in the organization that values
spending time doing this kind of upfront
work rather than the very very natural
tendency to jump from jump right in to
defining the problem
that's what organizations typically do
so a lot of it is working with other
people in the organization to lead this
process and bring others on board and
help them to see the value of it in the
course one of the things that we will be
talking about is leading innovation that
speaks to this directly and there's also
another essay p.m. course on managing
from the middle I think it is that helps
to helps project managers to see how to
make change across the organization from
the position that they're in
you know just to add to that um you're
not going to come out of a two-hour
session ready to be a design thinker and
hang out your shingle and that's not to
say you won't have tools that you will
use in your everyday world we we've had
lots of Timmy's who have learned mind
mapping and are now drawing all over
their fume hoods and their colleagues
are wondering where they can get some of
that and that's great we love that but
what we found by and large is it for
organizations simply having an executive
director of do more Design Thinking
doesn't work so well what does work are
having people work on real projects
using these tools where both are
committed they have skin in the game and
the projects are such that those winds
that they get can be communicated to the
larger organization and this gets to the
leading from the middle great thank you
the next question is how do you know
when you are there the right question
the right solution this tends to be a
common question from okay another great
one and you certainly know you're there
when you've run out of time and money as
a consultant that's that that does you
real quick but but seriously when Pam
talks about iteration the iteration is
the central way that you begin to find
out yes but in both iteration and
prototyping those two things are crucial
the iteration every pass through you are
getting closer to satisfying those needs
and it's not just simply sort of getting
the Hail Mary hoping it lands pass but
you are in by operating both in the
tangible space and understanding how
those prototypes are working not working
how you're building on the theories to
see how they work it's that combination
that begins to let you know if you're on
the right track yep absolutely and I'll
just add quickly to what you've said
Michael is
is going back to the the needs again
going back to that that place of
understanding and linking back to what
you've begun to understand about users
what I've seen fairly frequently is is
once we get over onto the prototyping
then the solution side that can sort of
spin out of control into really cool
solutions but it's critical to then
reach back and test that with you know
what did we learn how would this person
actually feel about this particular
solution so that there's this constant
testing in our own minds as well as
directly with users and just this is a
really important question one other
piece and Pam said you got a prototype
and for a lot of people it's like well
it's it's going to cost us you know two
three million dollars to prototype and
we would push back and there are a lot
of very different ways of prototyping of
displacing people's activities once
you've built this knowledge of
frameworks and culture and how things
are going you can have people behave and
act in very different ways ways that you
hope they will around your product or
service engage how that product or
service will work with how it in fact
having to go through the three million
dollars of building in and a lot of
creative approaches we will talk about
that as well agree and our last question
is how do you incorporate regulations
around that dominate your work to design
your projects some a lot of participants
have regulations that change often
thoughts on redesigning and rece coping
as these change that's another really
great question you know I think our
tendency is to see regulations and and
other inputs of that sort as constraints
and at some level they are constraints
right but they're all
so the opportunity space and what's
really critical is to two or those into
the process and incorporate them into
that set solution space so that they
actually so the solution actually works
with those regulations in terms of
changing regulations you know that's
there's a little bit more challenging
because it suggests much more dynamic
kinds of project management processes
and I guess I would be inclined to think
of that as a need in the process of
designing more suitable project
management processes you know along
those lines and we've just finished
working for a group of auditors and
trust me they have more regulations and
you can imagine and what they have
discovered is they've kind of stopped
thinking all right the regulations are
an excuse because I there's just nothing
else we can do this is what's dictated
and they're now coming to the
recognition that innovation and design
thinking are opening back up yet we have
to serve the regulations but they're all
sort of experiences we have been
ignoring and that we can design too as
well so the Pam's point the regulations
aren't an end right there they're
necessary beginning for your solution
space but you can open up beyond they're
just I know we're wrapping up here but
just to add one more example in the
medical device space we're using a lot
of design thinking in the medical device
medical device space and that's highly
regulated but the real opportunity is to
be able to design within that space and
take into account the regulations that
exist great Thank You Pam and Michael
this concludes the question and answer
portion for today thank you for
attending today's webinar project
innovation through design thinking as a
reminder you may now print Appy
F of the slides by selecting the print
to PDF option from the file menu at the
upper upper navigation bar for those of
you that weren't able to get audio on
the video we will be sending out a link
to that video along with the recorded
version of the webinar for you to view
once those are up and available there
are still many questions in the queue we
will stay in the live meeting to answer
a few more questions for those kind of
hanging out there so please for those of
you that your answers were quite or
answered please disconnect and for those
of you we suggest you stay oh thank you
you